this is sandra sanchez for nexstar
media's border report
we're in la jolla texas and behind me is
about 50
families that were apprehended by border
patrol agents
this morning crossing the rio grande
they're a group here of about 25
unaccompanied
grandchildren um range from oldest
to seemingly youngest we have been told
we're not allowed to show their faces
so we're just shooting them from behind
one of the people behind me did speak to
me
said they've been waiting here a couple
hours they came to this country
because they want a better life
um
um
one little girl was cold and they were
giving her a blanket
and as border patrol waited for a bus
another group of migrants emerged from
the brush
they joined the existing group of
migrants to wait
for a bus
[Music]
so
a border patrol medic asked them how
they were feeling as an initial
screening for coronavirus
and as the sun began to rise they were
loaded onto buses
behind me there's a group of migrants
who are waiting to be transported by
border patrol
we've been out at the spot all morning
and we have seen about 200 people
apprehended by border patrol agents
some are unaccompanied minors they've
been loaded on buses
there was a horse patrol even that
helped to round up some of the people
who tried to run
run one border patrol agent told me but
most of the people are just
giving up they want to be apprehended
they're coming to the united states they
told me for a better life
[Music]
texas i'm sandra sanchez